okay we're gonna work through these five
problems involving radicals and I'm
going to show you how to handle these
problems so number one we've got 5
square root of 3 minus 2 square root of
3 how do we handle that well you can see
we're working with the same type of
quantity both of them have square root
of 3 it's just that we have five of
these minus two of these that's going to
equal 3 square root of 3 now that was an
easy one let's do a bit more challenging
one say that the radicals are not
similar how do we proceed well the first
thing you want to do is try to simplify
each of the radicals as much as you can
individually and see if they have
something in common like we had in this
first problem and then combine you know
the like radicals so for number 2 square
root of 18 is really square root of 9
times square root of 2 and square root
of 9 you know is 3 times 3 gives us 9
square root of 2 over here square root
of 20 is really like 4 times 5 now
notice what I'm doing is I'm trying to
divide out a perfect square and so then
what we have here is square root of 4 is
2 times 4 is 8 square root of 5 and then
here square root of 8 is again 4 times 2
and then we have this 2 so square root
of 4 is 2 times 2 is 4 so minus 4 square
root of 2 notice that we've got 9 square
roots of 2 minus 4 square roots of 2
which is 5 square roots of 2 plus 8
square root 5 and we can't combine these
further they're just added we have to
have the same type of square root in
order to combine those together for
number 3 were moving into some
multiplication we've got 2 square root
of 3 times the quantity 4 minus 5 square
root of 3 so what you're going to do
here is you're going to take the 2 root
3 with the quantity on the outside
distribute it into the parenthesis and
we're going to simplify keep in mind
when you're multiplying you want to
multiply it like terms together what I
mean by that is that you know the
numbers that are on the outside of the
square root you're gonna multiply by one
another and the ones that are on the
inside of the square root you're gonna
multiply those together so here we've
got 2 times 4 that's going to be 8
square root of 3 when we distribute to
this group we have 2 times negative 5 is
negative 10 square root of 3 times
square root of 3 is square root of 9 so
notice I multiplied the numbers on the
outside and then the square roots
together so like terms square root of 9
is 3 times 10 is
30 so we just get a square root of 3
minus 30 and you've got it okay number 4
we're multiplying a binomial 2 terms
times another binomial two terms so what
you can do is you can either use the
foil method or you can distribute twice
okay so let's go ahead and take do that
so 3 times 4 is 12 3 times 5 root 7 is
15 square root of 7 negative 2 root 5
times 4 is a negative 8 square root of 5
and then the last terms here we've got
negative 2 times 5 which is negative 10
square root of 5 times square root of 7
is square root of 35 now we look to see
if we can simplify further 35 is just 7
times 5 there's not a perfect square we
can divide out of that same thing here 5
is just 5 and 1 7 is just 7 and 1 so
that's as far as we can simplify there's
no you know like terms we can combine so
this is our final result and then the
last one number 5 we have a binomial
squared and what you do when you have a
binomial square is you can think of this
as 6 square root of 2 minus 9 and
another 6 square root of 2 minus 9 so
squaring you have that quantity twice
right so now we're gonna do the same
thing we did in this first example we're
going to distribute so we have 6 times 6
is 36 and notice whenever you multiply a
square root times itself the square root
of 2 times square to 2 you just get the
number underneath which is 2 you could
say square root of 4 which is 2 but I'll
just make that 2 so this is actually 72
6 times negative 9 is negative 54 and
the square root of 2 comes along and
then now if we take negative 9 and
distribute negative 9 times 6 is
negative 54 square root of 2 and
negative 9 times negative 9 is positive
81 so if we combine like terms we get
153 minus 108 square roots of 2 and
that's our final result if you want to
see more problems involving radicals
I'll put a link to a playlist I did
right there going through all different
types of problems involving square roots
cube roots everything related to
radicals so I'll see you in those videos